this shows plainly how little we had
expected
much less prepared for war in july
1914 our entire diplomatic machine
failed the menace of war was not seen
because the foreign office
was so hypnotized with its idea of above
all
no stories its belief in peace at any
cost
that it had completely eliminated war as
a possible instrument of entente
statementship from its calculations
and therefore did not rightly estimate
the importance of the signs of war
innumerable are the pieces of evidence
that as early as the spring and summer
of 1914
when nobody in germany believed as yet
in the ontant attack
war had been prepared for in russia
france
belgium and england number one
as far back as april 1914 the
accumulation of gold reserves
in the english banks began on the other
hand
germany as late as july was still
exporting
gold and grain to the antante countries
among others
number two in april 1914
the german naval attache in tokyo
captain von nor
reported that he was greatly struck by
the certainty
with which everyone there foresaw a war
of the triple alliance
against germany in the near future that
there was a something in the air
as if so to speak people were expressing
their condolences
over a death sentence not yet pronounced
number three when our troops advanced in
1914
they found in northern france and along
the belgium frontier
great stores of english soldiers great
coats
according to statements by the
inhabitants these were placed there
during the last years of peace most of
the english infantrymen who were made
prisoners by us in the summer of 1914
had no great coats when asked why
they answered quite naively we were to
find our great coats
in the stores in the north of france and
in belgium
history can show nothing to compare with
the world war
of 1914-1918
it can also show nothing like the
perplexity which has arisen as to the
causes
leading up to the world war this is all
the more astounding
in that the great war befell a highly
cultivated
enlightened politically trained race of
men
and the causes leading up to it were
plain to be seen
the general situation of the german
empire and the period before the war
had become continually more brilliant
and for that
very reason continually more difficult
from the point of view of foreign
politics
unprecedented progress in industry
commerce
and world traffic had made germany
prosperous
the curve of our development tended
steadily
upwards the combination of this
peaceful penetration of a considerable
part of the world's markets
to which german diligence and our
achievements justly entitled us
was bound to be disagreeable to older
nations of the world
particularly to england this is quite a
natural phenomenon
having nothing remarkable about it
nobody is pleased when a competitor
suddenly appears and obliges one to look
on while the old customers desert to him
for this reason i cannot reproach the
british empire because of english ill
humor
germany's progress in the world's
markets
had england been able by introducing
better commercial
methods to overcome or restrict german
competition
she would have been quite within her
rights in doing so
and no objections could have been made
it simply would have been a case of the
better
man winning in the life of nations
nobody
can find it objectionable if two nations
contend against each other peacefully
by the same methods i.e peaceful methods
yet with all their energy daring and
organizing ability
each striving to benefit itself
on the other hand it is quite another
matter if one of those nations
sees its assets on the world's balance
sheet threatened by the industry
achievements and super business methods
of the other
and hence not being able to apply
ability like that of its young
competitor
resorts to force i.e to methods that are
not those of peace
but of war in order to call a halt upon
the other nation in its peaceful
campaign of competition
or to annihilate it
[Music]
we certainly did all that was possible
to meet england halfway
but it was useless because the german
export figures
showed an increase naturally we could
not limit our world commerce in order to
satisfy
england that would have been asking too
much
while on this subject i wish to call
attention to the delusion
under which prince lichnowski the german
ambassador to london
was laboring soon after he had become
ambassador
king george came to the embassy to
dinner the king's example was followed
automatically by the best society people
in london the prince and
princess were singled out for marked
detentions and exceedingly well treated
socially from this the german ambassador
drew the conclusion that our relations
with england
had improved until shortly before the
war
sir edward grey coolly informed him that
he must draw no political conclusions
from social favors and good treatment
accorded to him personally
nothing could give a better insight into
the difference between the english
and german mentality than this the
german assumed
social friendliness to be the expression
of political friendliness
since the german is accustomed to
express aversion and approval by means
of social forms
as well as otherwise he is very
outspoken about what he has on his mind
our acts were founded upon the clear
perception that germans could reach the
important position in the world and
obtain the influence in world affairs
necessary to her
solely by maintaining world peace this
attitude was strengthened moreover
by personal considerations
never have i had warlike ambitions in my
youth my father had given me terrible
descriptions of the battlefields of 1870
and
1871 and i felt no inclination to bring
such
misery on a colossally larger scale upon
the german people
and the whole of civilized mankind
old field marshal mulkey whom i respect
greatly
had left behind him the prophetic
warning
woe to him who hurls the firebrand of
war upon europe
and i considered as a political legacy
from the great chancellor the fact that
prince bismarck had said
that germany must never wage a
preventative war
the german resistance would be
neutralized if she did
whatever has been said in malevolent
circles about the existence of a german
party favoring war is a conscious or
unconscious
untruth in every land there are elements
which
in serious situations either from honest
conviction or less
lofty motives favor the appeal to the
sword
but never have such elements influenced
the course of german
policy the accusations especially those
which have been made against the general
staff to the effect that it worked for
war
are pretty untenable the prussian
general staff served its king and
fatherland by hard
faithful work and maintained germany's
ability to defend herself by
labors extending over many years of
peace as was its duty
but it exerted absolutely no political
influence whatsoever
interest in politics as is well known
was never particularly strong
in the prussian german army looking
backwards one might also say in fact
that it would have been better for us
if those in leading military circles had
concerned themselves a bit more with
foreign policy
therefore how the peace of versailles in
view of this perfectly clear state of
affairs
could have been founded upon germany's
guilt in having caused the world war
would seem an insoluble riddle if it
were not possible to trace the
tremendous effect
of a new war weapon vis-a-vis
the political propaganda of england
against germany
planned on a large scale and applied
with audacity and unscrupulousness
i cannot bring myself to dismiss this
propaganda by branding it with
catchwords
such as a piece of rascality since it
constitutes
an achievement which in spite of its
repugnant nature
cannot be ignored it did us more harm
than the arms in the hands of our
opponents
to us germans such an instrument of
insincerity distortion
and hypocrisy is not pleasing it is
something that is
incompatible with the german character
we try to convince our opponents with
the weapon of truth
as well as with other weapons
but war is a cruel thing
and what matters in it is to win after
all
to fire heavy guns at civilized beings
is not a pleasant matter
nor to bombard beautiful old towns yet
this had to be done
by both sides in the war
moreover we could not have developed a
propaganda on a large scale
like that of our enemies during the war
for the very reason that they had no
foes in their rear whereas we were
surrounded
in addition most germans have not the
gift to fit a scheme of
propaganda to the different
nationalities of the nations upon which
it is supposed to work
but just as the english were more than
our match with that terrible weapon of
theirs
the tank against which we could bring
nothing of equal efficiency
so also were they superior to us with
their very effective weapon
of propaganda and this weapon still
continues its work
and we are compelled still to defend
ourselves against it
over and over again
for there can be no doubt that the
unjust peace of versailles
could not have been founded upon
germany's war guilt unless propaganda
had previously accomplished its task and
partly
with the support of german pacifists
instilled into the brains of 100 million
human beings
the belief in germany's guilt so that
the unjust
piece of versailles seemed to many
justified
[Music]
i do not care what my foes say about me
i do not recognize them as my judges
when i see how the same people who
exaggeratedly spread
incense before me in other days are now
vilifying me
the most that i can feel is pity
the bitter things that i hear about
myself from home
disappoint me god is my witness that
i've always
wished what was best for my country and
my people and i believed that every
german had recognized and appreciated
this
i've always tried to keep my political
acts everything that i did
as a ruler and a man in harmony with
god's commitments
much turned out differently from what i
desired
but my conscience is clean the welfare
of my people
and my empire was the goal of my actions
you